Candid Truth. What is up everybody?
Thank you for joining us at Candid
Truth. We're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it. I just wanted to cover this because
you know what? This might be completely
old news to you. It might be a review
for you, but I want to get into who is
the beast of Revelation. Who is the
Antichrist that the Bible talks about?
Because I've been raised up in church my
whole life and there's always these
different uh beliefs like, "Ooh, is it
Obama? Look, he hates Christianity and
he's a Muslim and his name means
lightning from heaven and all this kind
of stuff and is it going to be the next
president? I remember when Bill Clinton
got elected and uh my friends who were
my age at the time, which I was a kid,
they cried when Bill Clinton got elected
because their parents were saying that
if Bill Clinton gets elected, he's the
antichrist. And then it was Obama. And
now, who knows? Like, dude, this is just
crazy how we're always looking for this
one world leader, one world man who's
probably an American president. And it
doesn't help when we watch things like
Left Behind and all this stuff who paint
the Antichrist as some one-man
individual who is
this charismatic leader that just hates
Christianity, though. He's like
obviously evil, right?
But we have to look at this and
understand that the Antichrist is not
going to look obviously evil. He's not
going to just hate Christians and kill
them in the streets because it's got to
be so deceptive that only the elect,
only a remnant will not fall for this
deception. Um I guess I guess you guys
have heard that two days ago the pope
died. Pope Francis died. And I think
it's interesting because there was um
there's
this prophecy of the popes and I saw
this on the history channel before Pope
Francis even got put in position and I
just want to kind of show you guys this,
react to this. Not sure if you guys know
about this uh prophecy of the popes, but
I'm going to skim through this because
History Channel always flags you for
copyright. It doesn't even matter if we
get flagged for copyright because we're
not monetized. So, we only exist thanks
to you donors out there because we've
been rejected both times that we've
applied for monetization. You can only
apply like every two or three months.
And both times that we've been able to
apply so far rejected for harmful
content. Harmful content. I don't know
how some of these other channels are
monetized out there, but thanks to you
guys, we are still still able to do
this. We depend on your support, so we
thank you and love you. And uh I want to
react to this. And like I said, I'm
going to skim through it some and pause
it and stuff just to make sure it
doesn't get copyright. Malachi Morg was
nothing less than a saint. But despite
so Malachi some saint prophet a Catholic
saint his faith in the mercy of God he
was forced to bear witness to a
terrifying vision of divine wrath a
biblical apocalypse. So he had prophetic
visions of an apocalypse that he
predicted would occur in our time.
I don't know why it says 2012 there.
They do the math and they say they think
it adds up to 2027. Maybe that's
something they figured out later.
Malachi Morg was the first Irish saint
to be canonized by a pope. He was known
to to have some supernatural miracles
associated with. So remember
supernatural and miracles doesn't always
mean from God. I think as Christians
we've lost all discernment with that. We
think if you see a miracle, I'm talking
even healings.
People have this concept in their mind
that Satan is just this big scary
monster and all he can do is bring fear
and death and all that stuff. But the
Bible says and we I I'll pull it up on
screen. Revelation says that there will
be miracle working demons in the last
days, lying signs and
wonders. Remember Job when he was
afflicted, he was afflicted by Satan.
Satan put boils on him. Now if Satan can
afflict a person, do you think that he
can pull that affliction away? Yes. And
if he pulls an affliction away, it will
appear to be a miracle and therefore
will be a lying sign and wonder. Now,
there's also another big misconception
that people think as Christians, look,
we can't be affected by Satan. Satan
can't touch me. I'm a child of God.
Look, we have, like I said, we've lost
all discernment. We say we're Christian
and we're watching all the filth of the
world. We're listening to all the filth
of the world. We're we're going to yoga
sometimes at our church. We got idols in
our house. We got literally Buddha
statues and all this stuff and we think
they're just beautiful decorations. We
are bringing things into our home.
Sometimes it's uh it could be maybe you
went on vacation and you bought some
kind of necklace or bracelet and that
thing was
uh dedicated to some false god and now
you're wearing it. There are so many
ways that we don't understand the
spiritual world, how Satan works on
rules, rules of engagement that God has
put in place. And Satan can only do what
God allows him to do. Now, it's like
this whole vampire myth thing that the
vampire can't come into your house
unless you invite him in, right? You
can't a vampire can't come in through
the window or through your door unless
you give him an invitation. You welcome
him in. That's the same way it is with
demons and Satan. But pretty much ever
since we've been reached the age of
accountability and we started living a
life of sin because we're all sinners,
we are giving Satan an invitation. And
when we become a born again believer, we
are to repent. Pick up our cross daily.
Daily. Repent. Pick up your cross daily
and walk the straight and narrow with
Christ. And that's hard. That is not
easy. It is not called the easy way.
It's called the narrow way that few will
be that find it. Broad is the way to
death and destruction. And many will go
there. In the last days, many will say,
"Lord, didn't we prophesy in your name
and do many wonders in your name?" And
he'll say, "I never knew you. Depart
from me. I never knew you, you workers
of
lawlessness. You workers of iniquity."
What does that mean? It means they
didn't surrender their lives to Christ.
And they still preached and they still
did many great wonders in his name, but
they lived a life of lawlessness. Jesus
says, "If you love me, keep my
commandments." How many times did he
have interactions with people and he
said, "Go and sin no
more." Oo, we think that, oh, sin no
more. Wait a minute. You're talking
about some legalism and all stuff. I'm
talking about the words of Jesus
Christ. Go and sin no more. Thank God
there's mercy and grace and forgiveness.
And even Peter denied Christ three times
and was forgiven. And David committed
adultery and murder and he was forgiven.
And Moses killed a man and all that
stuff. Yes, these people did. People of
God slipped up. But there's a difference
in slipping up because the word sin
comes from a archer term. You you pull
back that bow. You have your aim on the
bullseye. But when you let go, when that
arrow is in the midst of its travel, a
gust of wind blows it off course.
Unexpected temptation comes along and
you are you're not ready. You're not
prepared. And you fall for that
temptation. But immediately afterwards,
you said, "Lord, forgive me. I repent. I
did not mean to do that. I did not want
to do that. That was not what my
intentions were. Lord, forgive me. I
repent. give me the strength to continue
on and to not fall into this again. That
is vastly different than saying, you
know what, this weekend I'm going to
hook up with that chick who's not my
wife. This weekend I'm going to go get
drunk. You're premeditating sin. I'm
going to You know what? Right now, I'm
just craving um some marijuana and I'm
going to get in my car. I'm gonna First,
I'm going to count my money. I'm going
to get in my car. I'm gonna drive to the
dealer's house. This is all premeditated
stuff. This isn't like you were
heartbroken because of something that
happened and uh maybe the a person of
the opposite gender starts to console
you and one thing leads to another and
you can't help and it just something
happened. That's completely different
than premeditated. I'm going to do this
sin or to see a commandment and say, you
know what, it's very clear the
commandment says that, but it's not
really convenient for me. Um, it's not
what my family does. You know, my wife
wouldn't really go for
this. When you see it, when you know to
do right and do it not, that is
considered sin. iniquity, lawlessness,
rebellion is knowing what is right and
willfully continuing in that sin. And
that's when you start to grieve the Holy
Spirit. That's when you can grieve the
Holy Spirit to the point of no return.
And that is blasphemy of the Holy
Spirit. A lot of people are like, "What
what is blaspheming of the Holy Spirit?
What's the unpardonable sin?" That's it.
knowing to do right, living in habitual
rebellion to the point that you grieve
the Holy Spirit
away. I know this might be
controversial. You guys might not even
believe what I'm saying. You might
unsubscribe because of what I'm saying.
And thank you guys for getting us to
8,000 subscribers. I think we were one
away before I started this live. All
right, I'm already I'm already getting
fired up preaching in here, but I want
to continue watching this clip here with
him. He's most famous now for his
prophecy of the popes.
In 1139, Malach
11 1139 like that is a long time ago.
Kai made a pilgrimage to Rome to visit
the pope. While ascending one of the
city's fabled seven hills, he was
struck. Remember that. Remember that
city of seven hills? That's going to
come into what we're talking about by a
revelation from God. From God. Look how
they just like automatically assume it's
from God.
Remember, not only God can perform
miracles, even visions. How do you think
these people have out-of body
experiences going to the astral plane
and all this stuff that is not of God
and yet it's a vision? And the story
goes that he fell into a trance. a
trance. Uh, I don't remember anyone
falling into a trance in the Bible, but
you guys ask, you guys tell me. All that
night, he would mention these Latin
phrases, the
medit labor solis. Each one of these
Latin phrases would match up to the
reign of a particular pope. Okay. So,
he's getting a vision, a prophecy. He
believes it's from God. And these people
believe it's from God, I guess. And it's
about popes in the future. Remember,
this was like in the 11
uh 11,000s years. And in that vision, he
saw 112 popes up in 112 popes in his
prophecy of the future of the end until
the tribulation time till the end. the
tribulation time. And according to St.
Malachi's prediction, this end time
following the reign of the 112th Pope is
right around the corner.
We're at 111 now. Pope Benedict the 16th
is 111. So, this came out in 2018. See
this right here? History Channel. This
is the last pope.
This aired in August 12th, 2018. This
was before Pope Francis even stepped on
the scene. So when they were airing
this, they didn't know who was going to
be after this guy.
If Malachi's vision was true prophecy,
there will be only one more pope to
follow Benedict the 16th who So they
they say after this guy, one more pope.
Pope Francis came up next. According to
this prophecy, Pope Francis was the last
pope before the end of time and
tribulation. E turned 85 in
2012. In other words, our time may be
running out.
I believe it is. But why should we
believe him? Malachi didn't just predict
the number of popes before the end of
the world. He also predicted who they
would be.
Hm. Interesting. With startling
precision
[Music]
and what you find is an accuracy I would
say that exceeds
80%. Which
I So if a
prophet if a prophet of God has a
prophecy that exceeds
80%. Does that make them a prophet of
God? 80%. Is that enough?
If God gives someone a
prophecy, it's 100% sure. God didn't
give Daniel a prophecy that was 80%
sure. God didn't give John of Revelation
a prophecy that was 80% sure. I think
that's a red flag right there. I can
tell you that got me fascinated by these
prophecies and that he's one of the
greatest prophets I've ever encountered.
Oh my goodness. of course.
And what makes it amazing is he gets
more accurate as he gets to the end of
the list. In fact, some of the ones more
recently are quite astonishing.
You have Benedict the 15th, who's called
by Malachi
religio, which means depopula. That
sounds too close to depopulation.
religion devastated or depopulated. In
his reign, the Christian faith was
decimated. 25 million people dying from
World War I. It's also the time of the
Bolevik Revolution in Russia. And
scholars say that 200 million left the
Russian Orthodox Church to join the
Communist Party. Religion depopulated.
After him comes the papal giant John
Paul II who is called D labor solis
which means the son's labor through
eclipse. He was born in 1920 on a total
eclipse. Then when he died he was
actually buried during a solar eclipse
as well. Okay, that's just
weird. Born on a solar eclipse, buried
on a solar eclipse. Is that what he
said? Let me make sure. Eclipse.
which means the sun's labor to eclipse.
He was born in 1920 on a total eclipse.
That's crazy because we know this is all
about sun worship. If you don't know
that, now you
know. Sun worship is like the pinnacle
of
Satan's masquerade. is his god. His p
his
masquerade is the sun
god. Then when he died, he was actually
buried during a solar eclipse as well.
Obviously, people can't manipulate
eclipses. So apparently Malachi really
did see a vision of the future and it
would you would have to be divinely
inspired. I would say you don't have to
be divinely inspired just because
something came
true. Especially when when you're
talking about these satanic elitist who
have had this stuff planned for
generations. Satan has a plan. Satan has
a plan for one world order and he's got
a system that's rolling out and it's
happening. And if somebody's got to die,
you think Satan can't kill them off?
Come on, man. This is crazy.
For it to to match that accurately, that
seems to be a little more than
coincidence.
Yeah. Seems like a satanic plan to me.
Malachi's prophetic precision continues
with the current pope. By the way, if
you never noticed this before, you see
this hat, right?
Remember this hat, the fish head hat.
We'll get back to that. Continues with
the current pope Benedict
16th number 111. The final numbered
motto and that is the Gloria Olive, the
glory of the olive or from the glory of
the olive. There is a group of
Benedictines called the Olvetans. Their
symbol is the olive branch. the glory of
the olive would be the highest ranking
among them. And there he is. We thought
Malachi's correct again.
I'm not I'm not catching on to this one
yet. And now there's only one more pope
in the line. What did the olive have to
do with anything? We are very close to
the end of this prophecy.
[Music]
Okay, so there you have it.
Um, so I want to, like I said, this
might be old news. What I'm about to go
into, this might be
review. And I just know that this is
important. It is important because guess
what? If you if you believe in the
pre-tribulation rapture, prove it to me.
Show it to me in the Bible. It's not
there. We will uh Christ is coming at
the last
trumpet. And the last trumpet is when
the dead in Christ shall rise first. The
dead in Christ and those who are alive
and remain will be caught up to meet the
Lord together in the air. When? At the
last trumpet. How many trumpets are in
Revelation? Seven. When are they
sounded? At the When they're sounded, a
plague comes from God. So, if a trumpet
sounds and a plague comes, a trumpet
sounds and a plague comes seven times.
The last trumpet is when the dead in
Christ and the those who alive remain
meet up in
the meet together to meet the Lord in
the air. That means you just went
through the plagues. That just means
that the rapture is the second coming.
And if you don't believe me, please,
there's a video check out in their live
tabs. Check out a video on the rapture.
It's got a video u on the thumbnail.
It's got a country singer who just
recently came to this truth as well. And
I give every single verse about the
rapture in context. And it's so clear.
It's so clear that the second coming is
the rapture. And people say, "No, you're
talking about the second coming, not the
rapture." This No, it's the same event.
How many resurrections of the righteous
are there? One. So, when you see two
verses that say uh at the trump of God
and at the last trumpet, they're the
same. They're parallel verses. They're
telling you when the rapture happens,
it's at the last trumpet. And so it's
vitally important because so many
people, so many Christians think, "I'm
not even going to be here for this. I'm
not going to be here for no antirist and
mark of the beast. I don't got to worry
about that. I'm getting raptured out of
here." Guess what? You're going to have
a huge wakeup call when you are here for
the mark of the beast because you will
be. If you are alive through this, I'm
just telling you, there is no
pre-tribulation rapture. Get that out of
your mind. I'll prove it a 100%. I was
raised believing it. I watched all the
movies. I believed it until I started
reading the Bible myself and studying
line upon line and letting God's word
interpret itself. So, if you believe the
pre-trip rapture, I'm sorry, it's not
true. So, who is the Antichrist? Can we
know? Is it is it some one-man leader? I
want to go through some verses. Um,
first off, I want to go through these
visions, though, because in the book of
Daniel, you you can't understand
Revelation without seeing Daniel. Daniel
is the key to unlocking the book of
Revelation. Remember this,
too. Every single vision given to man by
God is symbolic. Every one of them.
Think about it. Joseph, I'm peeking this
microphone out.
Joseph had a dream of stalks of wheat,
bowing down to other stalks of wheat,
right? It had nothing to do with stalks
of wheat. It was about his family was
going to bow to him. Skinny cows eating
fat cows was another dream. It had it
was about a famine, but there was no
such there was really no skinny cows
eating other fat cows. Um Peter, this is
a controversial one. Peter had a dream
of a sheep being let down and there's
all kinds of unclean beasts in it. And
the Lord said, "Eat, Peter. Eat." And he
said, "No, I've never eaten anything
unclean." And people say, "Oh, yeah. Now
you can eat anything." Because Peter had
that vision. That is so false because
when you read when you when you read
read context is
king. Peter said, he didn't even know
what the vision meant. Wait, if it was
so simple as now I can eat anything, he
would have been like, "Oh, thank you,
Lord. or not can eat anything, including
jellyfish and poison ivy and poisonous
mushrooms. Come on. He said he didn't
even understand the vision until a
little bit later when he ends up at the
door of of a gentile. And then he says,
"Wait a minute. The vision about the
unclean beast, the Lord said, do not
call anything unclean that I've
considered clean." And it's about the
Gentiles. So again, a symbolic vision.
Same thing with Daniel. He saw beasts
rising out of the o out of the sea. Four
beasts. It's not a prophecy about
beasts. It's a prophecy about kingdoms.
And it tells you that it said these the
fourth beast which you saw was the
fourth kingdom. So the Bible interprets
itself. It gives us a key
code. Beast equals kingdom. Uh horns
equal kings or
kingdoms. Nebuchadnezzar had a dream
about a statue and it had different
metals in it. And the vision was nothing
about a statue. It was really about
kingdoms. But these the the amazing
thing about the Bible is that not only
does it interpret
itself,
but it it
it verifies
itself. The Bible says, "Study line upon
line, precept upon precept, here a
little, there a little, by the mouth of
two or three witnesses." That's four
times it's saying don't make entire
doctrines out of one verse. If you see a
verse and you think it means something,
it's guaranteed to be somewhere else in
the Bible that's going to back up that
belief. And so prophecy is the same
thing. It's called repeat and enlarge.
So like a telescope, at first you just
see a little bit of the prophecy and
then it tells it again and it gets
deeper with more detail and then it gets
deeper again with more detail. Repeat
and enlarge. So Nebuchadnezzar had this
dream of this image and it said that the
head of gold was Babylon. Well, the
first beast that rose out of the sea was
this lion with wings and it also
represented Babylon. Remember this lion
stood up like a man and was given a
heart of flesh instead of that heart of
stone. And that's exactly what happened
to Nebuchadnezzar, the king of Babylon.
He was a beast for seven years until God
gave him a heart of flesh. So we know
that this is about Babylon. And we know
that the the head of gold is about
Babylon because Daniel literally told
him, "You, king, are the head of gold."
And Nebuchadnezzar was like, "That's
right, the head of gold." But wait,
there's more. The chest and arms of
silver. Notice there's two arms that are
crossed together. So that means that
there was two forces, two nations
joining together and it was the Mes and
the
Persians combined to create Meo Persia.
Then there was this bear. The second
beast of Daniel's dream was this bear
that was raised up on one side and had
three ribs in his mouth. all of its
symbolic pointing
to Meo Persia because the Mes or the
Persians, forgive me, I can't remember
which one. One of them was more powerful
than the other and that's why it's
raised up on one
side and the and the chest and arms of
silver got two arms crossing. Then you
got this belly and thighs of bronze or
brass. It says it both ways in Daniel.
And that is Greece.
Greece was ruled by Alexander the Great.
And right here you see
this leopard with four heads and four
wings. What does a leopard represent?
Speed. Leopards are so fast. What does a
leopard with wings represent? Really
fast. I mean, it can
fly. Four heads represent the four
generals that worked
with Alexander the Great.
Um there I want to show you something
else because it's it's amazing. We have
the tools at our fingertips to prove and
to discover what the Bible um teaches.
So look at this.
Alexander the Great leopard. Check this
out. This is this is amazing. Alexander
the Great is literally sitting on a
leopard skin saddle.
So the Bible predicted this. I don't
even know when. Thousands of years
before Christ came on the scene.
Alexander the Great wasn't until way in
the future.
So the Bible is predicting at the time
that Daniel got this dream, Babylon was
the ruling power, the world
power. All the world must bow at the
sound of the instruments, right? They
must bow to the golden image. That was
the time period. And the Bible is so
predictively accurate in its
prophecies that it predicted
that Alexander the Great would be riding
on this leopard saddle. That is not a
coincidence. Then you see this long legs
of iron which represent the long reign
of Rome because Rome conquered Greece.
And then you see this beast that rises,
the fourth beast that rose out of the
sea in Daniel's vision had iron teeth.
Again, iron and iron. Now, this beast
has 10 horns, which that goes deeper.
Remember, this is repeat and enlarge.
So, you're going to get more of the
prophecy because the the statue of
Nebuchadnezzar, it told,
okay, Babylon, Meo, Persia, Greece,
Rome, and then it it talked about this
final kingdom at the bottom, but it
didn't give extra details. Then these
four beasts give a little more details
because now it's talking about 10 horns
and one of them or three of them were
plucked up by a little horn. All of this
is prophetic about a little nation
coming up and conquering. But I want you
to notice these feet of iron and clay.
It calls these feet partly of iron which
is what? Rome, right? It's still Rome.
So we know that the final kingdom is
still a little bit of Rome but also miry
clay which is dirty clay. The Bible says
that he is the potter and we are the
clay. And what is the church? The church
is us. The church is the body of Christ.
So and and what did he make us out of?
Clay. So, we're talking about a mingling
of iron Roman state system and a corrupt
miry church. A mingling of church and
state, but it's a corrupt dirty church
mixed with the government state of Rome.
It's so specific. a Roman corrupt church
state system is the last kingdom that
we're looking for in the last days. Now,
we we see some other things in the Bible
that this beast, there's a beast of
Revelation that had a fatal wound and
and came back to life from that fatal
wound. Did Rome ever fall? Yeah, Rome
suffered a fatal head wound in 17 or uh
in seven oh man, I can't remember the
date now. I'm rusty on this stuff now,
but Pope General
Berier, French General
Berier ripped the Pope off the throne
and the pope died in exile and that was
the fall of Rome. But now look around,
we got the pope's coming to the United
Nations and they're calling him holy
father and they're clapping. Every world
leader goes to bow down to the pope and
kiss his hand and shake his hand and do
all these things. Why in the world does
this little nation, this little kingdom
with a pope, a religious leader, have
all the world leaders flying to go meet
him? Why? Ask yourself why. Why? It
doesn't even make sense. How come Trump
just said, "Everyone must fly their
flags at half mass because this pope
died. Some guy in Italy that has nothing
to do with us in Rome." All right. So, I
wanted you guys to see the connection.
these these beasts are the same
prophecies
as Daniel uh the statue of
Daniel. But it does talk about
um three horns being plucked up. It
talks about a little horn rising up. I
want to show you
that Daniel little
horn. So, it says, I'm going to use
Bible Hub because I want you to see
different translations. I know I made a
video talking about how King James is
like pretty much the best translation we
have right now, but it's not always. It
It doesn't mean it's always 100%
accurate when it comes to the Greek and
Hebrew translation of a word. Sometimes
individual words are better in other
translations, to be honest. But right
here in the King James, it says, "I
considered the horns and behold," now
this is talking about the fourth beast
in Daniel, the fourth beast with the
iron teeth. He had 10 horns. "I consider
the horns and behold, there came up
among them another little horn. before
whom there were three. The first horns
plucked up by the
roots, and behold, in his horn were eyes
like the eyes of a man, and mouth
speaking great things. So, remember,
Revelation talks about the number of a
man, right? Now, we got this little horn
that rises up in Rome. Remember this
this prophecy, the final prophecy,
remember the final beast is Rome. This
beast is Rome. And that's what this
description is about. This beast says
that a little horn comes up. Now, this
is this is where it gets awesome. You
get to be a detective. You get to use
the technology that we have today to
prove that the Bible is 100% true and
and you can discover who the Antichrist
is. So, check this out. There's a little
horn which and we said that a horn means
what? Let's look. Let's let's look it
up.
Bible Daniel horn king
kingdom. I want you guys to learn how to
do
this. So check this out. The Bible
interprets itself. It says, "And the 10
horns out of this kingdom are 10 kings
that shall arise and another shall rise
after them." So we know that
horns are kings are
kingdoms. So check this out. If a little
horn rose among
Rome, then this must be a little
kingdom, right? A little kingdom Rome.
What? Check this out.
What is the world's smallest nation?
Check this out. What is the world's
smallest nation?
Oh, interesting. The smallest nation in
the world is Vatican
City. I I didn't give it any kind of
bias. I literally said, "What is the
world's smallest nation?" We're looking
for a little horn and the Bible talks
about and it's going to be in Rome. I
didn't even put Rome in there. The
smallest nation in the world is Vatican
City, the Roman Catholic Church.
Oh,
interesting. Now, I want to I want to
show you something else because now this
is starting to make sense. Every Okay,
the statue said Rome. The statue
actually said Rome and church state.
Church and state. Uh the four beasts,
the fourth beast said Rome because it
was iron teeth, but now it had a little
horn, which is a little kingdom. And we
just found out the little kingdom's
Vatican. So that's making sense because
Vatican is a what? A church state
system. A corrupt church and state. So
wait a minute. Daniel's or the
Nebuchadnezzar statue has church and
state mingled together. And then a
little horn which is Vatican City is a
church and state system. Is there what
about revelation? Because revelation
goes deeper about this beast. Let's see.
There was a what's the first beast of
revelation? The first beast of
revelation. There is this beast with a
harlot riding upon
her. I'm just clicking I'm just clicking
links, guys. I don't know. I don't know
who these websites are. I know that this
lady, Revelation Illustrated, I think
she's a Baptist or whatever. I don't
care. I don't I don't do denominations.
I'm doing
Bible and I'm going on record saying
that. All right, check this out. So,
there is a woman on a scarlet
beast with seven heads and 10 horns and
she's wearing interesting colors, purple
and scarlet, and she's got a golden cup
in her hand and she's drinking the blood
of the saints. This is all in this is
all in the Bible. Check it out. Re let
me so Bible hub
revelation
harlot purple
[Music]
scarlet I mean this is amazing that we
have the technology you know what in the
last days we got no excuse for ignorance
we have if when Christ comes none of us
will be able to say you know what I
didn't know I didn't have the resources
we live in the information age it's
willful ignorance the Bible calls it
willful ignorance if you don't know this
stuff. So, I'm wanting to give you the
tools. I want you to get excited about
knowing how to find the truth right here
in the Bible using the technology we
have. Okay? So, King James says, "And
the woman," now what is a woman and
symbols? Remember, Revelation is
symbolic. That might don't get
triggered. Revelation is symbolic.
There's not really going to be a harlot
riding a seven-headed beast. There's
not. There's not really going to be a a
woman wearing white standing on the moon
clothed with the sun. It's symbolic. And
what do they represent? There's a pure
woman which represents God's true
people, his church. And there's a harlot
who represents a false corrupt church.
And it and she's drinking the blood of
the saints and everything. She
persecutes God's people. Now look what
it says. And the woman, which is a
church, was arrayed in purple and
scarlet, and decked with gold and
precious stones, having a golden cup in
her hand, full of abominations, of
filthiness, and fornication. Now, what
does fornication mean symbolically?
Fornication means turning on God,
worshiping other gods. In the Bible,
when um God was leading the Israelites
through the wilderness and they started
worshiping a golden calf, that was
fornication. He said you went a whoring.
God said that you his people went a
whoring after strange gods. When you
worship other gods besides the one true
God and you follow his true
guidance, his ways is committed
fornication. So let me let me look up
something simple. What what do we see? A
woman which is a church arrayed in
purple. So we're going to look up church
purple scarlet gold. All right, let's
look it up. There's no bias here. I'm
not I'm not saying Rome, Vatican,
anything.
Church,
purple, scarlet, gold. And we're going
to click
images. Oh my goodness. Are you Are you
seeing what I
see? Huh? It's the official colors of
the cardinals and bishops are purple and
scarlet. And what is in the
hand of this person? Wait a minute. Open
open image and new tab. What do we see
here? A golden cup in his
hand. This is not coincidence. This is
prophecy. And in the end, nothing's
going to be hidden. That's what it says.
The Bible says that there will be
nothing hidden. Everything hidden will
come to light and be
exposed. Look at
this. Purple and scarlet and decked with
gold and precious stones. It is so
visual. This is a corrupt church. This
is a harlot who's committing fornication
on God's true ways.
God says, "Worship me this way." And
this corrupt church state system has
done everything opposite of what God
says. Call no man father. They say, "Oh,
call me father. Confess um they say they
call Jesus a blasphemer because he could
forgive sins." And yet they say, "We can
forgive your sins." They call the holy
father who can forgive sins. They have
idols everywhere in their church. Make
no engraven image and bow down to them.
And what do they do? Bow down to images.
This is crazy. Catholic images
bow. You will see people bowing down to
images. Um, I didn't erase part of
it. Look. What do we see here? What do
we see here? Fornication is what we
see.
Idolatry, worshiping the dead, talking
to the dead,
necromancy is what we
see. This is fornication on all
levels. So, are things adding up?
Absolutely. So, we see the feet is a
church and dirty clay. We see the little
horn was Vatican which is a dirty
clay iron Roman dirty clay.
Um then we see something that
says let me let me get back to that one.
So we we're we're looking at this harlot
right now. The harlot who's dressed in
purple and
scarlet and she's riding a beast with
seven heads. What's the significance of
the seven heads?
Let's check it
out. I'm going to search right here.
Seven
heads. I I I'm I'm so happy that this is
we can do this together. I want you guys
to be able to do this. Bible hub
Revelation seven
heads, which are seven
Check this out. This is
crazy. All
right. King James. And I stood upon the
sand of the sea, and I saw a beast rise
up out of the sea, having seven heads
and 10 horns, and upon his head 10
crowns, and upon his head the name of
blasphemy. I think that's interesting,
too, that it's blasphemy. This church is
blasphemous.
It does everything that the Bible, any
any description we have of blasphemy in
the Bible is
um forgiving sins and calling yourself
God. And they call themselves God. We're
going to find out how deep they actually
get. Not only call themselves father,
they call themselves the replacement son
of
God. Uh I think the next verse might
say, let's see, where does it actually
say what the seven heads represent? So
the Bible will tell us what the seven
heads are. Check this out. We don't got
to guess. That's what's amazing. You
don't have to guess about the Bible.
Look at this. And here is the mind which
hath wisdom. The seven
heads are seven mountains on which the
woman sits. Okay, so the woman is
Vatican. The woman who's dressed in
purple and scarlet. We just saw it. We
saw photographic proof that it is the
Vatican. Now, we see that she sits on
seven mountains. Seven
mountains. Uh, seven mountains.
Mountains. Mountains. I want you to
notice something else, though. Look at
this. City of seven hills. Didn't we
just hear that in that history channel?
I said, remember that? The seven
hills. Seven hills. So now now you can
just
search. What is what is the city of
seven
hills? What is the city of seven hills?
The city of seven hills typically refers
to Rome, Italy. Everything points to
Rome. We don't have to guess. This is
amazing. Why is my computer dying when
it's plugged in?
Uh
uh. It's plugged
in. Why is it
dying? See, Satan loves to attack. I
don't know how my computer's dying when
it's literally plugged
in. The city of seven
hills. So, now we have, let's go back to
this. We got iron and clay Roman state
state church mingling. We got a little
horn, the world's smallest nation,
Vatican City. We got purple and scarlet
church with do decked with gold and
precious stones. We saw that was
Vatican. We just saw that the she sits
on the city of seven hills. City of
seven hills is Rome,
Italy. This is insane. Now, I know that
the Bible talks about the number of a
man. Let's see what that
is. So, it says in the King James, well,
let's read the New King James because
this right here and his number is 63
score and six. We don't talk like that
today. The New King James says, "Here is
wisdom. Let him who has understanding
calculate." Calculate means what?
Addition, subtraction, right? Calculate.
Um, King James actually says, "Count the
number I like calculate better. The
number of the beast, for it is the
number of what? A man." Some people say,
"Oo, 66, his number is 666." So, a lot
of people read this and they're like,
666 is the mark of the beast. Not
necessarily. That's not what this says.
This is the only verse that says
anything about 666 and it doesn't
anywhere say that 666 is the mark of the
beast. It's the number of a
man. A man. It does say it's the number
of the beast, which is we know now is
Rome, Italy, Vatican, right? But there's
also a man. Who's the man that means
666? So I would say, let's see. If I
think Vatican and I think of a man, who
do I think of? The Pope, the one who
speaks blasphemy and all this stuff.
Great words. Let's see. Because remember
that little horn, it said he had eyes
like a man. speaks great blasphemies,
right? So, let's look at Pope
uh Pope 666. See what happens. Um oh my
goodness, AI
man, look at this. Uh the idea that the
pope is associated with the number 666
is often linked to the beast of
Revelation. Um says right here that he
wore a hat that said vicarious fail day,
which is Latin. Let's translate. Oh,
dude. Technology is getting way better.
Like, I didn't even know I could do
this. I highlighted that and I clicked
translate and it says vicor of the son
of God. You know what vicor means? A
substitute. So, he wears a hat. The pope
wears a hat that says, "I am the
substitute of the son of God." Wait a
minute. Isn't that an antichrist? When
you say, "I am Christ." And it's not
really Christ.
So literally the pope wears a crown
saying I'm the
antichrist. This is
insane. But what about this 666 thing?
It says however the pope's official
title is vicira christi which doesn't
add a 666. So I think AI is a little
biased here. What about this vicerus
fleet day because I've seen it on a
crown. Let's
see.
Hat
images by curious fle day. What is this
right
here? Open image and new
tab. Okay. Right there. I I see it by
Carvis Fle day. That's right there on
the Pope's tiara. A photograph taken
from the Vatican
Museum. Okay. Okay. So, it's not some
crazy conspiracy theory, right?
Um, so what if we took, remember it said
calculate, calculate the number, right?
This is, this isn't a number. This is
words. What words are
numbers? Roman numerals. Wait a minute.
It's a Roman ruler, right? This whole
thing is about Rome. Rome. Rome. Rome.
So, what if we add calculate like it
said addition? And what if we add these
Roman numerals together and see what
happens? Uh fail day
uh Roman
numerals equal
what? Let me see what the images have
here for
us.
Wow.
Wow. Wow. Mind
blown. Open image and new tab.
This is the Roman numerals being added.
Simple addition. Like it says, calculate
the number. Look, all these letters that
actually have a a numerical value
because A and R and S do not have a
numerical value in Roman numerals. 112
53 501 equals 666. Is this a
coincidence, guys? So, let's I I just
want to review again.
We saw
that purple and scarlet church is
Vatican. Smallest kingdom Vatican. City
of seven hills
Rome. Little horn
Rome. Iron and clay Rome. This is all
it. Like we can identify who the beast
is. If you've never if you've been in
churches and stuff and they're like we
don't know who the antichrist. Who is
he? Who is he? I want to look that up.
He you know what in the Bible Bible
uh let's see King James Bible
Antichrist
Antichrist verses about the Antichrist
right here in the King James. Let's see.
Uh these are actually about Antichrist.
I want just the word Antichrist.
Antichrist. All right. It only appears
like four times, multiple times here.
This is all this is every time it
appears in the Bible. For many deceivers
have entered into the world who confess
not that Jesus Christ has come in the
flesh. This is a deceiver and an
antichrist. So it doesn't say the
antichrist. Little children, it is the
last time. And as ye have heard that
antichrist shall come, even now are many
antichrists, whereby we know that it is
the last time. So even in John's day,
the antichrist was there. Uh who is a
liar? But he that denieth that Jesus is
the Christ, he is antichrist. You know,
I used to deny that Jesus was the
Christ. I was an antichrist. I was he
that den he that denith the father and
the son. And every spirit that confesses
not that Jesus Christ has come in the
flesh is not of God. And he
that and this is the spirit of
Antichrist whereof ye have heard that it
should come and even now already is in
the world. So the Bible doesn't say
we're looking for the antichrist. It
doesn't actually say we're looking for
the
antichrist. But it does talk about the
beast and a beast is a kingdom. And it
does talk about the number of a a man,
but that man has many different heads,
right? We've just seen so many different
popes. Like, how many popes
uh have there been
um 266 popes? Guess what? Every one of
those popes was an antichrist. Every one
of those popes was the leader and the
head of the beast system of revelation.
The first beast
is Roman Vatican papal system. And the
man is any pope that sits in that
position. Any pope that wears that crown
of authority that says I am the vicor of
Christ. I want to show you something
else because Revelation says, let me
show Bible hub Revelation Babylon.
Remember, Revelation's a symbolic book.
Babylon doesn't exist anymore. Hasn't
for thousands of years. Remember, it got
conquered in Daniel, in the book of
Daniel. But it talks about
Babylon because it's it talks about
Israel. Israel is not Israel in the book
of Revelation. We are Israel. There's
neither Jew nor Greek. We're all one in
Christ Jesus. That's what the Bible
says. There are no nationalities. So
stop looking to Israel. Stop saying we
stand with Israel and flying a hexog.
That's nonsense. The Bible doesn't say,
Revelation, prophecy does not say
anything about literal Israel. Israel is
us. We are Israel. So Babylon is the
opposite. Babylon is this corrupt
church. And what does it say in the in
the King James? says, "And upon her
forehead was the name written, Mystery
Babylon the Great, the mother of harlots
and abominations." You know why she's
the mother of
harlots? Because there are a lot of
churches that are still clinging to the
things of Rome. Still clinging to the
mother. The reason we are called
Protestants, the reason we are called uh
after the
reformation, we reformed the church. We
stepped away from Catholicism and we
became protest ants. We protested the
Catholic Church and we have forgotten
what the protest is all about. And today
you got preachers saying the protest is
over. We're all Catholics now. Kenneth
Copelan said the guy who he had on
there, he had a priest come on his
platform and say we're all Catholics
now. And the whole crowd cheered as we
join hands with the antichrist.
Literally mystery Babylon. Why does it
say Babylon? I want to tell you why.
Look at
this.
Babylonian god
Deeon. Check this out.
Deeon or Dagen was a sign significant
deity in ancient
Mesopotamia,
Mesopotamian and near Eastern religions
particularly among the Philistines or
Philistines.
Deegon. Why is it not saying Babylon in
here? I just typed Babylonian god
Deeon. Is Babylon even in here? There we
go. These these deities, they always
just they change over time. Rome and
Greek, they both have the same gods.
They just change. But look, Deeon, it
says origins and evolution. Deeon's
early forms as a fertility god emerged
in the Babylonian context. Babylon, what
is it? He is a fish. A fish
god. Remember I told you, look at that
pope's hat, right? Check this
out. Check this Babylonian
priest. Look at this Babylonian priest.
What does he have on his
head? I think it's interesting. He's
wearing a watch. What is on his head? A
fish. Look at the shape of this fish
mouth. Now check this
out.
Pope Pope
hat. Pope hat. Oh my. Are you kidding
me?
What? Dude, this is Babylon. Mystery
Babylon. There's nothing different.
There's nothing Christian about
Catholicism.
Everything about it is
Babylonian. They got IHS with which is
Isis Horus set. Let me show you. IHS
gods. There it
is right there. Isis Horus set IHS.
These are the Babylonian gods right
there and their church is full of
idols. So just a little history
here. There was a time when Constantine
was killing
Christians and everybody was running for
their lives and everything and
Constantine had this vision of the cross
in the sky on the sun and and he had
this conversion experience and that's
what he told everybody and I don't know
whether he had this real vision or not
whether this was a deception from Satan
or what but he said he became a
Christian and he started telling people
Look, I I will stop killing you, but you
have to worship this way. You have to
worship the way I tell you and you can
live. Don't keep your Jewish Sabbath.
That's called Judaizing. And if you do
that, we'll kill you. But you can keep
the venerable venerable day of the sun.
In fact, we're going to enforce the
venerable day of the sun. So, we will
force you to keep the pagan sun god day
and you can go to this temple with all
these idols. And if it makes you feel
uncomfortable, that's not really
Mercury, Mars, and Venus. That's Peter,
Paul, and
John. Some of these statues predated the
existence of Christ. And yet, they call
it Christ. There's there's a a statue.
Um, let me see if I can pull it up here.
There is a
statue statue of
God
carrying a lamb on
shoulders. Um, and this person, good
shepherd
statue, classical.
So yeah, this character right
here, some of these statues actually
predate the existence of Christ. And yet
when you see this picture, you'll think,
well, that's Christ. He's the good
shepherd. He's got the the lamb on his
back. This was all a corrupt system.
What does the Bible say that the dragon
is going to deceive the entire world?
What's the world's What's the world's
largest Christian denomination? What is
the
the world's
largest Christian
denomination? The world's largest
Christian denomination is the Catholic
Church, also known as the Roman Catholic
Church.
About 50% of all Christians identify as
Catholic. Is that
mindblowing? The one church that the
Bible identifies as the harlot beast
system, the Antichrist system, has the
most largest Christian population in the
world. And guess what? Many of the other
churches that are out there are still
clinging to the things of this church.
We fled this church because back in the
dark ages, they were killing anyone who
had the Bible in their own native tongue
because the Catholic church got rid of
all the Bibles and they made it only in
Latin. And only the Catholic priest
could read Latin. And so the only way
you were going to get the word of the
word of God was from a Catholic priest
who could tell you it said whatever he
wanted to make you do 50 Hail Marys and
climb these steps and whip yourself and
bow to the pope or be burned at the
stake. And if you were found with a
scripture, even one scripture in your
coat, you were burned alive for having
the
scriptures. True Christians were killed
during this time.
And this is the world's largest
denomination. We fled that persecution,
founded
America and created we founded on
freedom of religion and created the
Protestant movement, the Protestant
Reformation where we protested the
Catholic Church. And now what do you
see?
Churches joining with
pope. Man, you see all world religions
joining
together.
Um Kenneth
Copelan. Kenneth
Copelan. Wow. Look at this.
world's largest
denomination and you have supposed
Protestant churches joining with the
Catholic Church, joining with the
Antichrist. And many of these churches
still cling to the pagan traditions of
this church, like infant baptism, like
sprinkling instead of baptizing. You
know where sprinkling comes from?
Babylon. Check this out.
Babylon
uh
priest
sprinkle. I hope that shows
something. Yeah, right
here. You see what he's got in his hand?
He has a bucket of water and a little
wand and he sprinkles
people. That's where this whole Catholic
tradition came from of sprinkling people
from
Babylon. It's nowhere in the Bible.
Nowhere. And so this
system is the Antichrist system and all
the churches are joining with it. And if
you're not sprinkling and you're not
doing infant
baptism, what day of the week are you
going to church
on? Remember, it was Constantine that
started the venerable day of the sun
worship. God said, "Remember the Sabbath
day to keep it holy." Remember during
creation week? I I
keep I keep thinking that I can wrap
this up, but it's just it's too deep. It
it when you really dig, you you'll find
the truth. The truth will set you
free. Um let's read creation week.
Genesis
um
blessed
hallowed
seventh. Check this out.
Some people think that the Sabbath was
for the
Jews.
Um that it's done away with. It's in the
fourth commandment. It's literally the
fourth commandment. You read the fourth
commandment and it says, "Remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy." And then
it tells you what day that is. It says,
"For God created in six days and he
rested on the Sabbath day." And right
here when you read in the King James,
this is during creation. It says, "And
God blessed." This is Genesis 2:3. And
God blessed the seventh day and
sanctified it because he had rested from
all his
work. God rested. God doesn't have to
rest. He rested to demonstrate what he
wants us to do. He wants a relationship
time. He wants date night with us once a
week. One day a week he wants to spend
with us. And we're like, you know what?
That's for the Jews. You know what? I
got to work on that day. You know what?
I can't do that. That's legalism. That's
bondage. That's works. It's the total
opposite of works. It's don't work. It's
relationship time with God. It's the
only commandment of all 10 that have to
do with spending time with God. Any
atheist could not commit adultery or not
steal or lie. Right? What atheist is
going to remember the seventh day and
spend that time with God? None. It's the
only commandment that Christians will
keep. But they don't. They actually
fight against it. You know, it's
actually an atheist that would probably
tell a Christian, you don't even do what
the Bible says. The Bible says, remember
the Sabbath day. The atheist can see it
and the Christian can't. And the whole
thing is the Bible says that that the
Antichrist power is going to think to
change times and laws. Bible Hub Daniel
think change times laws. Look at
this King James. And he shall speak
great words against the most high. He
shall wear out the saints of the most
high. He shall think to change times and
laws. The only law God has that's based
on times is the Sabbath. And what do we
see that Constantine
Constantine
venerable day of the
sun right
here in 3:21 AD Roman inst Roman emperor
Constantine decreed that the first day
of the week Sunday would be observed as
the day of rest and not work referring
to it as the venerable day of the sun.
This was a shift from the Jewish
Sabbath, which falls on Saturday and was
known as a day of rest on the Roman
calendar. Look, I'm not this is this is
nonbiased. I'm literally just asking
Google for history. Constantine ver day
of the sun. I didn't say like, you know,
what does this church believe about
this? I'm looking at the Bible and
history and current events and using
resources that we all have at the at our
fingertips to prove that the Bible is
100% true to identify the Antichrist
100%. No one else can fulfill exactly
who the Antichrist power is, the Roman
Catholic Church. And it doesn't matter
that Pope Francis died. Guess what?
They're going to put somebody else in
power and he's going to be the
antichrist because everyone that sits in
that seat is the antichrist is the ruler
of that beast system. And one day
America who is the second beast of
revelation and that's a whole different
study in itself. But who's the most
who's the newest kingdom on earth? Who's
the world's superpower? It's America.
Let me show you this. There's going to
be an image of the beast, right? And a
beast is a kingdom. An image is a
reflection or a copy, a mirror image.
Right? So check this out. Um
Washington
DC
obelisk
dome.
So America has this obelisk and dome,
right? Let me open this up in a new tab.
So this is America right here. Obelisk
and Dome. For one, obelisk has nothing
to do with America. We This is
Babylonian, Egyptian, everything but
American. And if you guys haven't
checked out the Washington DC video we
did, click on the lives tab. Click on
the scroll down till you see Washington
Exposed. This is not a Christian nation
at all. Everything about it was founded
on humanism and false gods. And they're
not even hiding it. They put the names
right They put the names of false gods
right there on the ceiling. They got a
huge statue of Zeus right outside a
fountain. Now check this
out.
Vatican dome
obelisk. Check this
out. Wow, man. This is
so so just clear that
it's it's shaking almost like it's look
at this. That's Rome. That's
Vatican. That's America. You see the
similarities? America.
Rome. The beast. The first
beast and the second beast who is a
mirror image of the beast. The image of
the beast is right here. America is the
image of the beast. And guess what? It
calls the second beast, which is
America, a false prophet because all
because America is going to point people
to worship the first beast. That's what
it says. It says that the first beast
cause all or the second beast, which is
America, cause all to worship the first
beast, which is Rome. And that's why
it's a false prophet because what does a
prophet do? A prophet points people to
another god. Worship this
one. So I I feel like I can't end this
without saying what is the mark of the
beast? We know that the mark of the
beast according to the Bible and so many
people get hung up on one verse. One
verse that says you can't buy or sell
without it and therefore it's a
microchip. the microchip is the is the
mark of the beast.
No, you can't get hung up on one verse.
There's so many other verses that say
that the mark of the beast is about
worship. They worship the beast in his
image. They worship and if they don't
worship according to this way, they'll
be beheaded. If they don't worship this
way, they'll be thrown in prison 10
days. If they don't worship this way,
they won't be able to buy and sell. Not
being able to buy and sell is not it's
not currency. God is not keeping people
from heaven because of a currency. I
don't care if it's a microchip implant.
I'm not I'm not endorsing a microchip
implant. I would never do that. Don't
ever get a microchip implant. But you
can avoid a microchip at all cost and
still get the mark of the beast because
what is the mark of the beast? It's a
form of worship. Remember, they have
they have the mark in their foreheads or
in their hands. But remember, revelation
is all symbolic because God's people
also have a seal in their forehead. And
we don't think that God's people are
going to walk around with some seal on
their forehead. So why would we think,
well, God's seal is is spiritual. But
but the beast system, his is real. His
is real. No. Because revelation is all
symbolic. When it talks about taking it
in the forehead, it's talking about the
beliefs of your mind. If you believe in
this new one world religion that's
coming soon, I believe it's coming soon.
And it's going to look like coexist.
It's going to look like, you know, Trump
is saying that we're bringing religion
back. Don't fall for this junk. Trump is
saying we're bringing religion back and
we got AI surveillance everywhere.
Stargate, we're going to watch everybody
and we're bringing religion back and oh,
the this pope is gone, but we're going
to get a new pope. He's going to be nice
and conservative. And guess what? You
know what? We need to force people to go
to church because the world's just
getting so bad out there that if people
went to church, this country would get
turned around and so many Christians are
going to say, "That's a great idea.
Let's do it." Project
2025 says that Trump can enact any law
he wants to. Religious
laws and it's going to be on what day?
If you know this is going to get
everybody even the atheists and
everything are going to say you know
what the the banks are closed on Sundays
the post office is closed on Sundays the
DMV is closed on Sunday the government's
basically closed on Sunday sounds like a
good day to shut down during COVID when
we were locked in they said you know
what we saw uh we saw a positive change
in climate change when everybody was
locked up we need to take a day of rest.
They were saying this stuff. We need to
enforce one day that everybody rest.
Let's call it carfree Sundays. Let's
call it family day. It's going to sound
great. It's going to sound like love.
And and and it says when he says peace
and safety, what sudden destruction will
come upon them. Do not fall for the
system. There is going to come a a one
world religion that
enforces worship and that worship is
going to be on the venerable day of the
sun just like it was in Constantine's
days. And it was called they're called
blue laws. What are blue laws? Check
this out. What are blue
laws? Blue laws are state or local
statuses that restrict certain
activities, particularly commercial ones
on Sundays or religious holidays. They
are often referred to as Sunday closing
laws, Sabbath laws. Wait a minute.
Sabbath is not on Sunday. Sabbath is not
the first day, it's the seventh day, but
they call it Sabbath. So, they're
blending Sabbath and Sunday right
now. Or uniform day or rest laws. and
their origins are rooted in religious
traditions emphasizing the importance of
rest and worship on the Sabbath. But
it's not the Sabbath, it's Sunday. Now
remember, the Antichrist will think to
change times and laws. He's going to
enforce a system of worship. And what
does God say? What does Jesus say? If
you love me, keep my commandments. If
you love me, keep my
commandments. And how many people are
not keeping his commandments? How many
people are going to rise and say, "Lord,
Lord, didn't we do all these great
things in your name?" And he'll say,
"Depart from me. I never knew you
workers of
lawlessness." I want to show you
something because this is this is very
sobering.
Bible
hub. Um, in vain do they worship me
keeping. Check this out.
This is sobering stuff,
guys. King
James, this is verse
nine. So, he's talking about the
commandments literally right here. He's
saying, "For God, right up here, for God
commanded, saying, honor thy father and
thy
mother, and he that cursth father and
mother, let him die the death. But ye
say, okay, so we're we're sitting here
looking at commandments right here.
Right. Let me look at here verse three.
But he answered and said unto them, why
do you also transgress the commandments
of God by your
tradition? So Jesus is asking them, this
is Jesus' own words, why do you why do
you transgress the commandments of God
by your tradition?
For God commanded
this, honor your father and mother. And
then he says, and and then he goes on
here in verse six, he says, he shall be
free. Thus ye have made the commandments
of God of none effect by your
tradition, ye hypocrites.
Thi this people draw nigh unto me with
their mouth and honorth me with their
lips, but their hearts are far from
me. But in vain do they worship me
teaching for doctrines the commandments
of
men. This is sobering. This is Jesus.
This is New Testament. He says they
worship me in vain. It doesn't matter if
you worship Jesus. They worship me in
vain because they keep traditions over
the commandments of God. Please read
this. Matthew 15. Just read Matthew 15.
He's literally telling you the
commandments of God say this, but you're
keeping tradition and you're worshiping
me in vain because you keep commandments
of men. And Christians today will say,
you know what? Well, we keep Sunday
because that that's the day that Jesus
rose from the dead, but it doesn't say
that in the Bible anywhere. And they'll
say, "Well, you
know, it's a tradition."
Look, you can't just say,
"Well, Jesus said we can keep any day."
He never said that. Jesus is our rest.
Jesus is our Sabbath. There is no Bible
verse that says that. I want to show you
because they'll get it from Hebrews. I
feel like this is going to go on all
night, man. Um, let me see. King James
online. I just I feel like I have to
cover all my bases because I know that's
going to come up in the comments. you. I
guess we don't read Hebrews. Um,
Sabbath. Here we go. Hebrews 4. There
remainth therefore a rest for the people
of God. So, check this out. It says,
"Seeing therefore it remainth that some
must enter therein, and they to whom it
is first preached entered not because of
unbelief." So, there was people that
didn't enter into God's rest because of
unbelief. Because of unbelief, they
didn't keep the Sabbath. Remember that
guy? They got stoned to death because he
was picking up sticks on the Sabbath. It
didn't have to do with what he was
doing. It wasn't like, "Oh, you
shouldn't pick up sticks. You're going
to be killed now." It was his heart. He
didn't want to keep the Sabbath. He's
like, "Screw the Sabbath. I'm going to
do what I want to
do." And it says that they entered not
because of unbelief. again he limitth a
certain day saying in David today after
so long a time as it is said today if
you will hear my voice harden not your
hearts God's saying don't harden your
hearts to this you see the commandment
you see the fourth commandment stop
making excuses today is the day of
salvation harden not your hearts for if
Jesus had given them rest this is where
they get it from then would he not
afterwards have spoken of another day
whoa wait a minute It's saying, wouldn't
he have spoken of another day? But he
didn't. There remainth therefore a rest
of the people of God. For he that is
entered into his rest, which is what?
The Sabbath. He also hath ceased from
his own works as God did from his. How
did God and how did God rest from his
own
works? On the Sabbath day, the seventh
day, we just looked at it. It says, "For
he that has entered into his rest, he
also has ceased from his own works as
God did from his." You cannot twist this
into saying, "Jesus is our Sabbath."
No. Jesus said, "Keep my commandments."
And then it says, "Let us therefore let
us labor therefore to enter into that
rest, lest any man should fall into the
same example of unbelief. For the word
of God is quick and powerful and sharper
than any two-edged sword." He's telling
us, look, God's word has the answers.
Just do what it says unless you enter
into unbelief. Now, there's one that
says,
um, because everybody wants to say,
well, it wasn't it wasn't in the New
Testament. Jesus never said nothing
about it. That's interesting because
um Jesus said right
here, right here in Matthew
5, think not. Matthew
5:17, think not that I am come to
destroy the law or the
prophets. I am not come to destroy the
law, but to fulfill. And people say,
"Yep, fulfill. He did it. Yeah, he did
it. He walked it out perfectly to show
us that it can be done. But he said if
this is means people say, "Oh, that
means it's gone." Wait a minute. He
said, "I come not to destroy, but to
destroy." I I've come not to destroy,
but to get away get rid of. It doesn't
make sense. He said, "I come not to
destroy, but to walk it out perfectly to
show you it can be done. For verily I
say unto you, till heaven and earth
pass, not one jot or tit shall pass, in
no wise pass from the law, till all be
fulfilled. Whosoever look, till heaven
and earth pass, heaven and earth is
still
here. Whosoever there shall whosoever
therefore shall break one of these least
commandments, and shall teach men to do
so. So you're not keeping it, and you're
teaching others. Hey, you don't got to
do
that. If you break the least commandment
and shall teach men so, he shall be
called the least in the kingdom of
heaven. But whosoever shall do
them and teach them shall be called
great in the kingdom of heaven. So don't
call me a legalist and a Pharisee for
doing what Jesus said. I'm doing it and
I'm teaching others. And don't think
that you're going to be in the kingdom
because it says they're going to be
called least in the kingdom of heaven.
You know what this means? It means those
who are in the kingdom of heaven right
now. Angels are looking down calling you
the least. This should really be worded
um those who break the least commandment
will be called least by the kingdom of
heaven. The kingdom of heaven is looking
down calling you the
least. And just to prove that Jesus did
talk about the Sabbath, actually it's in
Matthew 24. We know Matthew 24 is all
about the the last days, right? It's
about the tribulation. And he says, "But
pray ye that your flight not be in the
winter, neither on the Sabbath day."
Jesus said, "Look, in the tribulation
that's coming, there's still a Sabbath.
Pray that your flight not be on that
day."
I hope this was eye- openening for you.
I hope that this helped you guys to see
that prophecy is sure and true and it's
coming to pass right now that you can
verify this stuff with technology we
have today. I hope that this I hope
somebody here that this was new to them
because I remember the first time I saw
this 10 years ago or so. I was just like
like mind blown like how have I been in
church my whole life and nobody could
identify the antichrist. Nobody could
identify the beast power. And there's
actually more. or I didn't even cover
everything. Somebody actually said right
here, I don't even know what it says
yet. Let's see. You forgot the real
meanings of the words. It is necessary
to know the real meanings. Research by
yourself. I'm not sure if that's talking
about something else, but this chat is
going off and I haven't even been able
to read it, but I pray that you guys
will get in God's word. Jesus is coming
soon. All the signs point to Jesus
coming soon. All the signs point to
there is tribulation coming and there's
UFOs in the skies and there are popes
dying and there are presidents saying
that we're going to bring religion back
and we got AI surveillance that's going
on and everything is just going into
chaos and this is they're going to bring
peace and safety order out of chaos. Are
you ready? Are you ready for this
deception that is going to deceive
everyone? The whole world. The dragon is
coming to deceive the entire world
except the very elect. If it were
possible, they would be deceived. But
they're not. It's an elect, though. It's
a
remnant. I I can't believe I can't stop.
What about the remnant? What about the
remnant? What are those? What's the
description of the remnant? Bible hub.
Revelation remnant. Oh, this is so good.
This is so
good because remember the very elect
will not be deceived. But who are those
elect? They are a remnant. The dragon
was wroth, which means angry with the
woman, which is the true church, and
went to make war with the remnant of her
seed, which do what? Which keep the
commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ. Look, some
people say Jesus had new Jesus had new
commandments. I keep those. know that
keep the commandments of God made it so
clear. Look, it's actually there's more
there's more revelation
um commandments actually. Let me just
type it in here. Let me do uh King James
online. All right. This is just so
important,
guys. No, I typed the wrong thing.
commandments. All right, we're going to
look up the word
commandments in
Revelation. The last book of the Bible
all about prophecy. Definitely New
Testament. Last book of the
Bible. Oh, I hope I can just find just
Revelation. Oh, man. This is all out of
whack. All right.
uh KJV
revelation
commandments. So we just saw that the
remnant keep the commandments of God.
Now this Revelation 22:14, blessed are
they that
do his commandments that they may have
right to the tree of life and may enter
into the city and into the gates into
the city. So, who are the ones that are
going to be blessed and can enter into
the city gates? Those who do his
commandments. Look, you guys say that
we're not going to be judged by our
works. But you look up that word works.
Just in the book of Revelation, I know
your works. I'm coming to judge you by
your works. It says it over and over.
I'm not saying we're saved by our works.
We're not. But Jesus said you'll know
them by their fruit. Not because they
say, "I'm a Christian." Not because they
believe. The demons believe and
tremble. That's in James. The book of
James says, "I'll show you my belief by
my works. You I'll prove to you I
believe. Just watch me. Just observe me.
See my works. Not because I'm earning my
salvation, but because I've been
transformed and I believe in God. And
I'll prove I believe because I'm going
to do what he says. I believe him and
I'm going to do it." And there's one
more. There's one more verse that
says Revelation 14:12, "Here is the
patience of the saints. Here are they
that keep the commandments of God and
the faith of Jesus." The patience of the
saints. The dragon is coming to attack
that remnant that keep the commandments
of God. The patience of the saints are
those who keep the commandments of God.
And those who can enter into the gates
of the city are those who keep the
commandments of God. I love you guys. I
thank you guys for being here. If you
guys want to support this ministry, you
can do so by going to
candidruth.org. We depend fully on you
guys. We are not monetized on YouTube.
They have denied us twice for harmful
content like this. If you guys want to
support this ministry, you can do so.
Even a dollar, every little bit helps.
Cash App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. Um if you
like t-shirts, we got t-shirts. You can
check out our store. We get about $5 per
uh shirt that we sell on
there. And we love you guys. We can't do
this without you. Thank you so much for
being here. We will catch you next time
on Candid Truth.